هناك بعض الأماكن التي لا تتوقع
أن ترى فيها دبًا وهذا أحدها
الشاطئ ولكن تأكد من ذلك وهذا
ليس كلبًا سألته قبل أن نعرض لكم
هذا الفيديو وهو عبارة عن دب أسود تم رصده وهو
يسبح في خليج المكسيك  قبالة
ديستين فلوريدا اليوم، يبدو الأمر وكأنك
تركب الأمواج قليلاً، لماذا لا تنضم
إلى حشد الشاطئ المذهول، أه، أنت
تعرف أحد الأشياء التي أنا متأكد من أن
الناس كانوا يقولونها هناك في مكان الحادث
هو مرحبًا يا أطفال، لا تفعلوا ذلك.  لا تداعب الدب،
لكنك تعلم أن هذا هو بالضبط ما
رأيته إذا كنت على الشاطئ في ديستين
فلوريدا في وقت سابق من اليوم، صرخات الدب
بدلاً من سمكة القرش أعتقد أنها قد تكون
شيئًا جيدًا ولكن من الواضح أنها استمرت في
الهروب إلى الكثبان الرملية القريبة
يقول كابتن محلي إنه
شاهد دببة تسبح من قبل ولكن أصبح
لدى المزيد من الأشخاص كاميرات الآن ولهذا السبب
تمكنوا من الحصول على تلك اللقطات اليوم،
أشياء مذهلة